friedrich merz kann sich ein schmunzeln
auch nicht verkneifen
fraktionsvorsitzende ag natürlich für
die cdu hier gerade gewonnen und
bestätigt im hochsauerland als
direktkandidat herr merz um sich das
noch mal auf der zunge zergehen zu
lassen markus stöger steht für moderne
er steht für zukunft er ist der kandidat
der herzen und all das ist armin laschet
nicht ausrufezeichen ausrufezeichen wird
sich die cdu wird sich armin laschet von
dieser schlacht erholen ich denke wir
werden im laufe der nächsten tage und
wochen schon eine veränderung in der
stimmung sehen bin mir ziemlich sicher
dass wir auch über den sommer eine
völlig veränderte stimmungslage in
deutschland haben wo sie herkomme aus na
ja wir werden einfach die zahl der
impfungen wird jetzt rapide steigen
ich denke mal wir werden auch irgendwann
im laufe des sommers aus dem locker und
- teilweise herauskommen und ich komme
ja nun auch aus nordrhein westfalen und
kann das glaube ich hier in dieser runde
authentisch sagen wir leben in einem gut
regierten bundesland armin laschet ist
ein erfolgreicher ministerpräsident in
nordrhein westfalen
ich sehe was er seitdem er 1900 2017
ministerpräsident wurde im land
verändert hat die koalition mit der fdp
funktioniert reibungslos wir haben ein
richtig gut besetzt das landeskabinett
das ist jetzt alles noch einmal das ist
ja auch ein bisschen für berlin in das
kanzleramt und es ist ein bisschen die
blaupause aber es ist natürlich nicht
die blaupause wäre aus ihrer sicht
markus söder der bessere kandidat
gewesen hat wir hatten zwei gute
kandidaten und das war ja im grunde
genommen eine art luxus problem aber aus
diesem luxus ist zunehmend ein problem
geworden weil die entscheidung so lange
ein problem geworden
ja gut aber ich sage man immerhin wir
haben zwei respektable kandidaten gehabt
die nun beide wirklich gut vorbereitet
und gut geeignet waren und sind für das
amt des bundeskanzlers und wir hatten
die qual der wahl und wir mussten uns
entscheiden und die entscheidung ist
gefallen es ist eine schlacht so sehen
das viele und so sagen dass viele die
frage es kommt man über sätze wie diese
weg die tatsächlich nicht von der basis
stammen sondern von ministerpräsidenten
und minister
wir haben uns im osten abgestimmt das
klare profil markus söder heute abend
kann man keine entscheidung durch
knallen gegen die gesamte deutsche
cdu/csu basis außer nrw hat sich kein
landesverband geäußert dass seine
mitglieder zu ihrem weitestgehend
akzeptierten bundesvorsitzenden stehen
viele werden enttäuscht sein wenn der
bundesvorstand genau das gegenteil
beschließt was ihnen am herzen liegt mit
markus söder haben wir die besten
chancen
ich habe lieber einen kanzler der csu
als der grünen hamas wie bringt man das
wieder nochmal wie kann man eine solche
verlorene schlacht drehen in einen
hoffnungsfrohen wahlkampf wegen die
infektionszahlen werden nicht reichen
das image von armin laschet zu drehen
das stimmt wir werden natürlich auch
programm und team noch brauchen grünen
haben das in einer anderen reihenfolge
gemacht hat wir aber wir machen das
jetzt und wie sie sich fühle mich so ein
bisschen erinnert an das jahr 1979 80
als französisch strauß über helmut kohl
viel härtere worte gefunden hat als die
die wir da gerade noch mal gesehen haben
er hat ihn ja für völlig ungeeignet
gehalten bundeskanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland zu werden
oder sie öffentlich gesagt und er musste
in der zu geben das ist einer der
erfolgreichsten kanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland geworden ist
also ich bin da ehrlich gesagt ziemlich
entspannter ist schuld daran dass es so
weit kommen konnte dass minister sagen
das ist nicht unser kandidat weil unsere
basis nicht dafür ist und es ist nicht
unser kandidat weil der von der csu
eigentlich besser ist ja also nach
meinem geschmack haben wir mit der
entscheidung zu lange gewartet
armin laschet hat damit zu lange
gewartet ja ich hab das ja auch schon im
januar gesagt dass wir noch im
wettbewerb um die um den parteivorsitz
miteinander standen ich hätte eine frühe
entscheidung bevorzugt ich habe diese
drei monate nicht verstanden warum das
jetzt unbedingt bis april gehen musste
das hätte man alles früher machen können
aber gut das wasser ist unter der brücke
durch die entscheidung ist jetzt
getroffen
und ich neige dazu jetzt nicht lange
zurück zu schauen sondern jetzt müssen
nach vorn blicken und wir haben in
diesem land so viele themen und schon
wieder im austro regierung habe ich
gewartet wann immer sie nach vorne
schauen wollen kommt der wega wo kann
ich schon mal verspricht markus söder
der kanzlerkandidat der herzen sie
eigentlich der parteivorsitzende der
herzen
herr merz hat die cdu in ihren augen hat
die union zum zweiten mal den selben
fehler ein herzproblem die cdu hat die
entscheidung getroffen 2018 auf dem
parteitag 2021 auf dem parteitag ich
habe mich zweimal zur wahl gestellt habe
zweimal knapp verloren
ob daraus in diesem jahr aber die
schlussfolgerung gezogen dass ich bereit
bin jetzt mit zu helfen und ich sage
auch mal an alle diejenigen die jetzt
mit mir zusammen auch ein stückweit
leiden unter dieser situation wir haben
jetzt sehr viele austritte aus der cdu
in allen kreisverbänden in deutschland
ich will den einfach sagen bleibt in der
cdu es wird auch wieder besser und wir
halten zusammen und wir sorgen dafür
dass wir ein gutes team sind und man
unter dieser bedingung eben unter diesen
verhältnissen jetzt eigentlich dann
wahlkampf macht darüber reden wir
nochmal zu ihnen was heisst das noch mal
er hat sich die partei hat sich die cdu
zwei mal eigentlich gegen den kandidaten
der herzens entschieden indem sie nicht
denjenigen namen der wenigstens für die
andere hälfte der partei stand ja gut
aber es war eben die größere hälfte die
sich so entschieden hat die kleinere
hälfte knappe andere hälfte hat sich
anders entschieden
aber wissen sie freuen da ich bin auch
in der der in der demokratie unseres
landes ein anhänger der repräsentativen
demokratie und das gilt auch für
politische parteien
ich möchte auch nicht dass aus
politischen parteien bewegungen werden
sondern dass es parteien bleiben und
dass dieser staat auch eine
repräsentative demokratie bleibt und
dazu gehört dass man mehrheit zu
entscheidungen akzeptiert auch wenn sie
einem vielleicht mal im einzelfall sie
haben fallen im oktober des letzten
jahres gesagt dass teile des partei
establishments sie als
parteivorsitzenden verhindern möchte sie
haben ganz bewusst diesen kontakt zur
basis dieses ich spreche eigentlich für
die normalen menschen in dieser partei
und gegen das ist
jetzt gehören sie dazu jetzt sind sie
ist ich wollte ja sogar vorsitzender des
establishments werden müssen
selbst das ist gar nicht
erklärungsbedürftig ich habe im letzten
jahr hat interveniert als es erneut
versuche gab diesen parteitag zu
verschieben und das habe ich für falsch
gehalten und da ich habe mich nicht
anders dagegen zur wehr setzen konnte
als mit einer öffentlichen wortmeldungen
habe ich das so gemacht und stehe dazu
und wenn ich es nicht gemacht hätte
hätte dieser parteitag ziemlich sicher
im januar nicht wäre er nicht hätte er
nicht stattgefunden hat sie glauben
dieses partei das sagen wir heute viele
die das damals nicht so richtig
verstanden haben die sagen mir aus der
rückschau als recht gehabt
und wer war dieses partei ist gut also
dass freuen da ist ja nun nicht erklären
dürfte ich nicht das war das waren aber
große teile der parteiführung damals die
mit guten oder weniger guten gründen
diese verschiebung wollten aber
geschenkt hat stattgefunden
wenn sie kanzlerkandidat geworden wären
anders rum wenn sie im januar
parteivorsitzender geworden wären
wen hätten sie eigentlich gefragt oder
auch überhaupt nicht gefragt um
kanzlerkandidat zu werden wen hätten sie
angerufen angehört von wem hätten sie
zustimmung erfahren wollen oder einfach
markus söder und ich waren verabredet
für den fall meiner wahl unmittelbar
danach miteinander zu sprechen und ich
hätte in diesem gespräch mit markus
söder darauf wert gelegt dass wir
schnell entscheiden ich hätte jedenfalls
keinen sinn darin gesehen drei monate
mit der entscheidung zu warten ob die
csu das akzeptiert hätte ob alle in der
cdu das akzeptiert hätten ist nun schnee
von gestern und ist aufgabe für die
historiker interessanterweise hat markus
söder sich im januar die bestimmt auch
wieder nicht am vierten vierter
korrekter weise die einbeziehung von
angela merkel gewünscht in die kür des
kandidaten für die kanzlerschaft er
sagte ein unions kandidat könne ohne
ihre unterstützung ohne merkels
unterstützung kaum erfolgreich sein
angela merkel hat sich demonstrativ
rausgehalten aus dieser kandidaten kür
zum schaden der cdu also hat sie aber
makel hat ja im jahr 2018 den
parteivorsitz abgegeben und das
kanzleramt behalten wollen
die cdu hat das damals akzeptiert
es waren sich alle darüber im klaren
dass das wie sie sich ausgedrückt hat
ein wagnis ist das wagnis ist ziemlich
groß geworden aber das ist jetzt auch
entschieden und wir haben jetzt heute
den 21ten april und in fünf monaten sind
bundestagswahlen also ehrlich gesagt
auch das ist eine frage für die
historiker und keine frage mit der ich
mich jetzt noch lange beschäftigen
angela merkel ist ja aber jemand an dem
sich wenigstens markus söder noch
orientiert hätte und er hat sie im
grunde immer umarmt er hat ja sogar noch
gesagt merkel also verbal umarmt merkel
stimmen kriegt man nur mit merkel
politik das ist hochinteressant er hat
sich an ihre seite gestellt er hat sich
vor sie gestellt und hinter sie gestellt
sie glauben das hat er alles nur gemacht
um chancen zu hause sprechen sie diese
kandidaten sprechen sie darüber mit
markus söder selbst ich bin nicht sein
interpret er aber er hat nun 2018 auch
mit der bundeskanzlerin einen sehr
harten konflikt öffentlich ausgetragen
da war er auf der anderen straßenseite
unterwegs also es kommt wie es kommt und
dieses hieß es die entscheidungen sind
getroffen
glauben sie dass markus söder jetzt
klein beigibt oder wird es jemand sein
der immer am gartenzaun steht oder
jemanden am gartenzaun stehen lässt der
liste sagt also klein beigeben ist noch
nie eine eigene art eines bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten gewesen das wird
auch bei markus höher nicht anders sein
und er steht nicht am zaun und am rand
sondern steht mitten auf dem rasen um im
bild zu bleiben
er ist als ministerpräsident des
freistaates bayern eine wichtige person
vorsitzender der csu und da wir
gleichberechtigt auch mit dem
parteivorsitzenden der cdu
wir sind eine union eine
fraktionsgemeinschaft und insofern
spielt der bayerische ministerpräsident
und parteivorsitzende csu eine wichtige
rolle und das wird auch so bleiben
werden sie klar sie jetzt im wahlkampf
der nicht mehr sehr lang ist die chance
haben tatsächlich wahlkampf zu machen
und trotzdem mit angela merkel weiter zu
regieren in dieser situation ist armin
laschet jetzt man muss sich
positionieren man muss eben auch
wahlkämpfen man will sich vielleicht
auch distanzieren von dieser kanzlerin
wenigstens wollen sie das
nein wir schließen im september eine
erfolgreiche 16 jährige regierungszeit
ab und wir sprechen im wahlkampf über
die zeit danach
ich mache kein geheimnis daraus dass ich
bestimmte dinge auch ändern müssen
schauen sie in den bereich der
energiepolitik schauen sie aber auch in
den bereich der umweltpolitik da haben
wir einiges nachzuholen und besser zu
machen
aber wir reden nicht über die
vergangenheit wir reden dann über die
nächsten zehn jahre und armin laschet
hat das zu meiner wirklich großen freude
auch so ausgedrückt hat gesagt wir
stehen vor einem modernisierungs
jahrzehnt in deutschland das ist ja auch
schon ein stück abstand auch zu einer
mit der spd beteiligten bundesregierung
wo vieles eben nicht ging
und da haben wir den anspruch an uns
selbst das besser zu machen
wie kann man jetzt aber wahlkampf machen
mit einer partei die in ganz großen
teilen nicht auf der seite dieses
kandidaten ist wie soll das gehen
die sachsen anhaltiner heben schon den
finger und sollten unbedingt soll
friedrich merz nach sachsen anhalt
kommen wo gleich landtagswahlen sind wie
macht man wahlkampf wenn man an den
kandidaten hat der nicht sie also auch
da gibt es historische parallelen rede
helmut kohl hat in der union auch lange
zeit sehr sehr harte kritik bekommen
auch in der eigenen partei wir haben
1989 auf dem bundesparteitag in bremen
fast eine abwahl von helmut kohl als
parteivorsitzender erlebt nach acht
jahren im amt des bundeskanzlers
dann kam die deutsche einheit und hat
das glänzend gemacht solche phasen gibt
ist und durch solch ein feuer muss man
durch und ich muss mal sagen ich bin ja
auch nicht unkritisch was armin laschet
betrifft aber dass er das durchgehalten
hat und dass er die nerven gehabt hat
auch diese tage jetzt anfang dieser
woche durchzuhalten ein bundeskanzler
der bundesrepublik deutschland muss
stehvermögen haben und muss gute nerven
haben und das hat er gezeigt
also hätten sie das auch mit markus
söder zusätzlich gemeinsam dass sie
beide unterschätzt haben was für ein
harter hund armin laschet ist also
zumindest muss ich sagen ich habe großen
respekt davor und ich war mir in den im
verlauf dieser 48 stunden von sonntag
bis dienstag nicht ganz sicher aber das
durchhält
und ich muss sagen respekt
wir fragen uns natürlich mit ihrer
freundlichen genehmigung was sie
anstreben
in dieser regierung in die sie
vielleicht hinein gegner hat ihnen am
entlastet etwas angeboten lieber
wirtschaftsminister lieber
finanzminister was würde friedrich merz
gerne werden also fröhlich märz möchte
am 26 september 2021 im hochsauerland
ein überdurchschnittlich gutes
wahlergebnis aller cdu erzielen ja aber
endlich ich nehme das wirklich ernst und
ich habe immer gesagt dass der bundestag
das parlament ist unser wichtigstes
verfassungsorgan in diesem land hält
sich das parlament eine regierung und
nicht die regierung ein parlament auch
wenn hin und wieder ein anderer eindruck
entsteht sie wollten im januar schon
wirtschaftsminister werden sie wollen
dann im september erst recht
wirtschaftsminister werden oder lieder
überhaupt mich beworben ich bin gewählt
worden am letzten samstag ich habe zu
diesem thema etwas gesagt er habe mich
auch dafür entschuldigt dass das nicht
besonders klug war aber das ist damit
jetzt auch erledigt und jetzt kümmern
wir uns darum dass wir wahlkreise
gewinnen und ich möchte vor allem meinen
wahlkreis gut gewinnen und dafür tue ich
auch sehr viel
die cdu habe ihren politischen kompass
verloren haben sie gesagt könnte es sein
dass die hälfte die andere hälfte der
partei einfach nicht in ihre richtung
na ja also ich habe am letzten samstag
72 prozent der stimmen in einer
streitigen delegierten entscheidung
bekommen und ich bin ziemlich sicher
dass große teile unserer mitglieder das
erwarten wir haben 400.000 mitglieder
aber wir hatten vor 20 jahren 800.000
ich werde mich jetzt auf den weg begeben
auch viele zurückzuholen die ausgetreten
sind jedenfalls bei mir zu hause weil
ich einfach das gefühl habe dass da
viele enttäuscht sind auch ein bisschen
deprimiert sind in der regierung gibt es
verschleiß in der regierung muss man
kompromisse machen mit den
sozialdemokraten allemal die gefallen
nicht geben aber ich finde die cdu muss
wieder ein bisschen mehr profile haben
ein bisschen klarer sein ein bisschen
deutlicher sagen wofür sie eigentlich
steht
ring frei eröffnet ist die runde
dorothee bär ist bei uns eine der
stellvertretenden vorsitzenden der csu
frau bär sie haben sehr schön gesagt
dass ein markus söder nicht antritt um
zu verlieren wird er denken sie jetzt
klein beigeben wird er armin laschet
wirklich unterstützen hundertprozentig
unterstützen ohne groll
ich liebe diese formulierung ohne groll
wird er ihn unterstützen also zunächst
einmal bin ich wahnsinnig dankbar dass
unser parteivorsitzender ein angebot
gemacht hat weil es ja nicht so war dass
die csu gesagt hat wir wollen jetzt
unbedingt den kanzlerkandidaten stellen
sondern es kam mir ein wahnsinniger
druck vor allem auch aus der cdu heraus
aber vor allem auch aus der bevölkerung
heraus lässt sich nicht verleugnen dass
das ganze letzte jahr permanent bis zum
heutigen tag und eigentlich sei der
entscheidung noch wesentlich mehr
die rufe nach markus söder wahnsinnig
laut sind friedrich merz hat gerade so
schön erzählt was ja sehr traurig ist
was mich auch als csu natürlich traurig
stimmt dass so viele aus der cdu
austreten
bei der csu es gerade das gegenteil der
frau sind leute über 1000 leuten wir
sind auf heute erstmals in einem mit
teilen deutschlands aus allen teilen
deutschlands aus allen teilen
deutschlands online mitglied geworden
das heißt markus söder ist unheimlich
beliebt die csu ist unheimlich beliebt
ich gebe zu das habe ich auch nicht
jedes jahr so erlebt dass wir
tatsächlich auch als partei bundesweit
auf so eine wahnsinnige resonanz stoßen
das ist ein tolles gefühl so jetzt
müssen sie auch wenn sich zu freuen und
sie müssen mir erklären darf mich schon
freuen weil ich finde dieses ganze jeder
ist so miesepetrig und will ich mich
erklären wir gefühl macht man für den
zweitbesten wahlkampf naja als er setzte
sitzt auf der bank haben sie gesagt und
der zweitbeste ist jetzt ja auf den
thron zu tragen ich habe immer vom
besten gesprochen so und ich mache dann
natürlich aus meinem herzen keine
mördergrube ich bin der festen
überzeugung nicht nur dass markus söder
ein herausragender kanzlerkandidat
gewesen wäre sondern ich bin auch fest
überzeugt dass er ein hervorragender
kanzler gewesen wäre oder ein
hervorragender kanzler ist warum weil
wenn wir ihn nominiert hätte
bin ich auch fest davon überzeugt hätten
wir auch die kanzlerschaft definitiv
geholt so jetzt wird es ein bisschen
schwieriger dass es auch kein geheimnis
dass sieht man natürlich jetzt auch an
den umfragen beispielsweise aber
deswegen ist die wahl noch nicht verlor
aber es wird härter definitiv wird
markus söder zu gucken wird er ihn
wirklich unterstützen und wird er nicht
jede woche mit einer kleinen stichelei
um die ecke kommen und ihm das leben
schwer machen sie meinen solche
sticheleien wie sie jetzt von den grünen
und den hab ich zu hören waren oder
welche sticheleien meinen ich meine
tatsächlich sich zu melden und zu sagen
ich bin der der für modernität steht ich
bin der der für wahre demokratie steht
ich bin der der die menschen an der
basis wirklich anspricht das war ja sehr
deutlich ist noch nicht mal eine
stichelei es ist eine deutliche
erklärung ich kann das eigentlich besser
als du aber er ist ja er steht ja für
modernität er spricht ja auch zum
beispiel wählerinnen extrem gut an es
ist sehr wichtig dass wir zum beispiel
auch bei den wählerinnen ein sehr sehr
gutes ergebnis bekommen weil die uns
auch immer überdurchschnittlich gewählt
haben und da steht ja natürlich als
moderner ministerpräsident mit einem
paritätischen kabinett auch für aufbruch
für zukunft die versöhnung von ökonomie
und ökologie ist bei ihm herausragend
aufgehoben das ist doch alles kein
geheimnis und da freue ich mich
natürlich nicht nur als seine
stellvertreter den sondern genauso wie
friedrich merz bin ich kandidatin für
den deutschen bundestag
und natürlich wird markus söder alles
dafür tun dass die csu in bayern ein
herausragendes ergebnis einfährt weil
die cdu ganz genau weiß man kann als
union keinen kanzler stellen wenn es
nicht mindestens in bayern das beste
ergebnis von allen bundesländern gibt
sonst geht es schon mal gar nicht und
dann werden sie jetzt tapfer in bayern
armin laschet plakatieren also in meinem
wahlkreis möchte ich ehrlicherweise nur
mich plakatieren und bin dann mal ganz
weit muss man dann mal schauen wer auf
die plakate kommt ja das heißt ist
natürlich eine frage danach mit welcher
mit welchen grundgefühl man das macht
cem özdemir für bündnis 90 die grünen
hier heute in der sendung sie haben sich
aus persönlichen gründen auch erstmal
für armin laschet gefreut aber im grunde
müssen doch die grünen auch die arme
hochreißen und sagen okay die union hat
sich für den schwächeren kandidaten
entschieden also erst mal in aller demut
umfragen sind umfragen da kann sich noch
viel ändern das war sehr schön auch
dafür bin ich lange genug dabei habe ich
höre mir das jetzt an und denkt so ein
bisschen
gerade irgendwie im falschen film ich
fühle mich zurückgesetzten die 80er
jahre grüne kreismitgliederversammlung
alles durchgestochen steht am nächsten
tag in der presse heute eben dank
internet stets in echtzeit in bild und
welt faszinierend ob das wirklich wirbt
für unsere demokratie wage ich zu
bezweifeln und ich habe jetzt den
eindruck den ich ihnen zuhöre frau bär
und die zitate von herrn söder
jetzt ging es erstmal um die k-frage die
kanzlerfrage jetzt geht es
offensichtlich um bse frage die
schuldfrage
alles das was herr söder gesagt hat was
sie sagen wir sind in reden ja gar
öffentlich hier die entscheidung ist
doch getroffen
spätestens nachdem die entscheidung
getroffen ist wie man ich muss sie nicht
coachen
dann ist doch klar jetzt gibt es einen
neuen chef der ist es und ich bin
vielleicht nicht aufgestellt worden um
ein bild aus dem fußball zu nehmen aber
dann ungestützt sich doch nur eine
mannschaft sie liefern doppel lauter
zitate ich muss mich doch gar nicht
vorbereiten auf die nächste talk show
ich muss einfach nur dorothee bär und
markus söder zitieren wenn ich über
armin laschet rede
und genau so dass sie die artikel kann
ich denn am montag nach dem angeblich in
trauer einsamkeit vielleicht nicht
direkt mit der bild-zeitung am tisch das
mag sein aber zum thema
basisdemokratische partei die grünen hat
man sich zu zweit getroffen
man hat entschieden um an conwert ist es
zeit interview was heute erschienen ist
von robert habeck hier verstehe das
nicht
vorsitzender angeblich für minister
partei mit keinem einzigen wort warum
annalena baerbock aus inhaltlichen
gründen besser ist sondern einfach nur
sagt naja weil seine frau ist
ehrlicherweise wenn das jemand von uns
gemacht wenn friedrich milch so was
gesagt hätte der oberschule der republik
aber robert habeck der darf wundenlecken
der darf total bitter stößt seine tränen
auf der steilen treppe trocknen ganz
ehrlich also da haben sie doch die
bürgerinnen und bürger waren zwei starke
kandidaten müssen kann halt schauen sie
die grünen haben viel verändert in der
republik eines kümmern nicht verändert
das kanzleramt kommt halt nur eine
person also musste klar sein
zwischen den beiden gibt es eine
entscheidung aber bei uns gibt sogar
keinen öffentlichen streit redet irgend
jemand schlecht über habe redet irgend
jemand schlecht über werbung
wo sie fit kein einziges zitat nein auch
er redet nicht schlecht über sich so wie
er sagt nur ich wäre es auch gerne
geworden
große überraschung und dann muss sie bei
unseren journalisten kollegen die wir
heute aus pandemie gründen nicht am
tisch begrüßen sondern zugeschaltet aus
berlin zugeschaltet
ich möchte gerne anfangen mit markus
feldenkirchen geschätzter spiegel
kollege herr feldkirchen alles nicht so
schlimm
oder ist dieser graben innerhalb der cdu
im grunde genommen nicht zu kicken
es war schon extrem was wir da die
letzten 14 tage erlebt haben und ich
glaube es erfordert sehr viel disziplin
von beiden seiten damit das jetzt in ein
produktives momentum umgewandelt wird
und bei allen eigenschaften die
wahrscheinlich auch frau bär ihrem
ministerpräsidenten zu sprechen würde
allen positiven eigenschaften eine hat
er bislang noch nicht so ganz unter
beweis gestellt nämlich die gabe sich
zurückzunehmen
bescheiden aufzutreten sich tatsächlich
für andere in den dienst zu stellen
das hat jetzt marcus würde die einmalige
gelegenheit das quasi auch mal unter
beweis zu stellen wenn das gelingt sehe
ich für die union durchaus noch
gelegenheiten das ruder rumzureißen ich
meine das ist das spannende an der
politischen situation in diesem jahr
wir haben bereits ende april und es
steht immer noch nicht fest dass die cdu
wieder das kanzleramt übernehmen wird
war in den letzten wahlkämpfen nicht der
fall da war das rennen fast zu dieser
zeit zumindest in dieser frage schon
gelaufen insofern ein spannendes jahr
jeder kann mit 25 26 prozent am ende
theoretisch den bundeskanzler stellen
auch die union aber wir haben
tatsächlich die situation dass wir es
nicht wissen die union kann am ende
stärkste partei sein es kann sein dass
die grünen vor der union landen und
selbst die spd ist noch nicht so weit
abgeschlagen das man noch nicht sagen
kann ob sie am ende vor den grünen noch
landen und die fdp um das vollständig zu
machen ist so knapp derzeit hinter der
spd
dass dieses rennen auch noch offen ist
sofern tatsächlich bei der
schnelllebigen zeit ist alles möglich
und ist in ihren augen vorstellbar herr
feldenkirchen sie haben markus söder
versucht so schön zu beschreiben horst
seehofer hat über ihn mal gesagt er sei
von ehrgeiz zerfressen ist es möglich
dass er tatsächlich abwartet und nach
einer verlorenen wahl dann entspannt
noch mal antritt jogi löw darf auch noch
eine em verlieren glauben sie gehört hat
psychogramm ich glaube dass er es
wirklich wollte dass er die eine
einmalige situation jetzt gesehen hat
nach einem jahr corona bekämpfung wo
bayern zwar bei weitem nicht die beste
bilanz aufzuweisen hat aber er zumindest
die perfekte performance hingelegt hat
er hat sehr gut inszeniert insinuiert
dass er alles im griff habe das ist im
kontrast armin laschet offenkundig nicht
geglückt also ich glaube markus söder
war aufgrund des corona der korona
inszenierung und des managements ich
würde es mal beides so nennen auf dem
höhepunkt seiner popularität armin
laschet genau an dem zeitpunkt wo markus
söder nach langem zögern gesagt hat ja
ich bin bereit ich trete an war armin
laschet auf dem tiefpunkt das halbe land
zerbrach in häme über ihn stand da wie
ein dödel vor allem nach dem interview
bei ihrem kollegen markus lanz also
wirklich auf dem auf dem tiefpunkt
seines ansehens hat söder dann quasi den
anspruch angemeldet und er war fest
entschlossen das ding jetzt
durchzuziehen und es war mega mega knapp
das muss man sagen
insofern ich glaube das war jetzt eine
riesenchance also auf irgendwas wie die
konstellation in vier jahren wieder ist
ob dann ein cdu-kanzler armin laschet im
amt ist da wird dann natürlich nicht an
markus söder übergeben ob es er sich
wünscht es jetzt eine andere regierung
gibt weiß ich auch nicht und ob es dann
nicht wieder andere leute in der cdu
gibt die diese kandidatur für sich
beanspruchen
also ich glaube es war für markus wieder
schon eine verpasste chance eine
verpasste chance und damit sind wir bei
claudia kade der kollegin politik
ressort chefin von
frau k de die frage von beginn ist diese
schlacht eben diese verlorene schlacht
wie wieder zu kitten ist die partei ist
die cdu zu kippen wird jetzt fertig märz
im osten die süder stimmen einfangen
können die sonst markus söder geholt
hätte ja die große frage ist das in der
tat die cdu scheint in die falle getappt
zu sein dies mehreren parteien schon
schwer gemacht hat nämlich dass man eine
funktionärs logik angewendet hat man hat
eine nach einer funktionärs logik
parteivorsitzenden gewählt und nach
dieser gleichen logik entgegen einer
stimmung oder umfragen logik eben auch
einen kanzlerkandidaten und wir haben
bei der spd gesehen dass das anders
gelöst wurde da hat man gemerkt wir
haben in einer langwierigen
mitgliederbefragung einen spitzenduo für
den parteivorsitz auserkoren aber uns
ist irgendwie klar mit denen kommen wir
bei den wählern nicht richtig an und
haben dann einen anderen
kanzlerkandidaten gekürt bei der union
ist das jetzt anders gelaufen union ist
aus meiner sicht im moment wirklich gar
nicht mehr der richtige begriff da ist
sehr sehr viel zerbrochen
in der cdu selbst und mit der csu dann
eben auch wer mir gesehen was frau bär
eben angesprochen hat markus söder
stichelt natürlich weiter es gab heute
eine öffentliche wirksamkeit öffentlich
wirksamen aufruf die online
mitgliedschaft der csu wahrzunehmen das
kann man eben aus dem gesamten
bundesgebiet haben heute sind es hat
funktioniert das ist für mich das
zeichen dass söder mitnichten am zaun
stehen wird und still sein wird und
laschet bleibt aus meiner sicht jetzt
eigentlich nicht viel anderes übrig als
zu versuchen die anhänger von friedrich
merz als es um den parteivorsitz gegen
die überschneidungen haben jetzt mit den
anhängern von söder einzubinden und die
forderung aus sachsen-anhalt scheint mir
logisch friedrich märz bei armin laschet
irgendwie ziemlich weit oben im
wahlkampfteam unterzubringen weil ich
kann herrn merz der auskunft geben wie
weiter schon gediehen ist
also das ist die aufgabe die laschet
jetzt hat er muss auf diese große gruppe
in seiner partei zu gehen und damit sind
wir bei friedrich merz und fragen ihn
mal unabhängig davon dass die kollegen
in sachsen anhalt sich das schon
gewünscht haben sind sie bereits fest
gebucht auf wahlkampftermine herr märz
in sachsen anhalt oder ist der arzt im
der verabredung den sachsen anhalts
hinter am 6 juni landtagswahlen richtig
wir haben leider in den ostdeutschen
ländern mittlerweile eine wieder sehr
viel stärker gewordene afd
in sachsen anhalt eine sehr schwierige
konstellation in der landesregierung und
ich habe reiner haseloff zugesagt dass
ich ihm dabei helfe diese wahl auch zu
gewinnen und wir planen das jetzt im
augenblick noch sechs wochen zeit aber
ja wir sind dabei das ganz konkret
vorzubehalten und würden sie immer noch
sagen dass es mit ihnen mit ihrer hilfe
gelingt die afg zu halbieren
die formulierung stammt aus dem jahr
2018 ich habe sie zu 1920 nicht
wiederholt weil sich die lage zu
mindestens in ganz deutschland etwas
geändert hat in ostdeutschland leider
nicht die situation ist eben leider so
dass wir in westdeutschland überwiegend
mit den grünen konkurrieren in
ostdeutschland wo die grünen praktisch
keine rolle spielen mit der afd
und da werden wir uns sehr viel stärker
darum kümmern müssen und halbieren ist
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt wahrscheinlich
ein zu hoher anspruch aber deutlich
reduzieren um vor allen dingen dafür zu
sorgen dass zumindest in sachsen anhalt
die cdu die stärkste fraktion im landtag
bleibt das glaube ich geht und dass tom
sagt zu widersprechen nun gerne aber in
sachsen anhalts im winter
stabilitätsanker der regierung ihre
partei das regieren würde dass wir den
in der mitte hessens waren das deshalb
wächst aber es ist eben leider so dass
wir in sachsen anhalt nur noch diese
konstellation überhaupt haben in
thüringen ist die situation ähnlich
schwierig also man muss den wählerinnen
und wählern auch sagen wenn ich eine
stabile mit ihr haben wollt dann geht
der weg eben nur über diese parteien und
ganz sicher nicht über die linkspartei
und ganz sicher auch nicht über die fdp
zeigen wie sehr wird dass armin laschet
schaden wenn er friedrich merz im grunde
genommen zu unter anderem auch zu seinem
ostbeauftragten machen muss weil die
sich herzlich bedanken für eine
wahlkampfhilfe von armin laschet ich
glaube es kann überhaupt nicht schaden
im gegenteil
ist dringend auf hilfe angewiesen von
friedrich merz aber vielleicht auch noch
von anderen beliebten prominenten damen
und herren aus seiner partei weil es ist
tatsächlich so bei allem was wir bisher
schon gehört haben armin es ist noch nie
jemand von den volksparteien zumindest
von union und spd so angeschlagen so
zerzaust und was die umfragen betrifft
von so einem niedrigen niveau in ein
bundestagswahlkampf gestartet also
insofern wird er nicht nur friedrich
merz und andere aktivieren und offen
gesagt das ist aber auch kein geheimnis
das hat er schon zum teil seiner
kandidatur gemacht dass er sagt ich muss
nicht alleine vorne stehen ich bin nicht
so der ago egomane also ein anderer
ansatz als markus söder ich bilde ein
team und da soll sie jeder sich
entfalten können klingt erstmal gut ob
das in diesem sommer mit der reduzierten
enthusiasmus mit dem seine partei jetzt
in diesem wahlkampf startet tatsächlich
funktioniert ist die große frage aber
wie gesagt kann eigentlich nur darauf
hoffen dass genug mitmachen